we're going to begin with this because
we've got an exclusive new interview
with brianna taylor's boyfriend his name
is kenneth walker
and he's telling cbs this morning he
cannot shake the trauma from the night
that she died
over the weekend protesters gathered in
taylor's hometown of louisville kentucky
and around the country demanding justice
over her death in a botched police raid
one year ago
walker was at that louisville rally and
was with taylor the night police raided
her home
the two were in bed at the time and
walker thought they were intruders
so he fired one shot from his weapon
that by the way he was legally
legally allowed to have and charges
against him were permanently dismissed
last week
we spoke with kenneth walker and his two
attorneys yesterday
every day feels like march the 14th to
me
every day does and i'm sitting right
here
today and i'm feeling tired tired
what are you tired of i'm tired of
having to get up every day and you know
and my life is it's changed i'm the only
person who has to deal with it every day
rihanna taylor's just a you know a
hashtag to other people but
she was something bigger than me of
course and it's hard to wake up every
day
and see you know her name and see her
pictures
and everything all over the place you
know but it's also like
that needs to happen because she still
hasn't gotten justice
yeah as we sit here today no one has
been charged
with her murder exactly
only one officer brett hankinson faces
charges for his actions at night
for wanton endangerment for shooting at
the apartment next door
last october two members of the grand
jury responsible for deciding charges
told us
they were never given the option of
charging the officers with murder
what did you think when you heard that
we were very surprised by that
only reason i wasn't surprised because
the way the whole situation has already
played out i'm still sitting here right
here as the only person who's been to
jail
and i didn't kill anybody what's that
man get me on your knees
walker was arrested and charged with
assault and attempted murder
accused of shooting sergeant jonathan
mattingly during the raid
walker's legal team says ballistic's
evidence does not prove his bullet
struck mattingly
last week a judge dismissed those
charges permanently
you were sort of in limbo kenneth
because they could have charged you at
any time without the charges being
dropped
so when you got the news that they had
been dropped did you feel relieved
when i heard the news i was definitely
relieved but also it's kind of like a
smack in the face too
because there should have never been any
charges in the first place
what does that say to you about the
initial charges since they've now
dismissed it
his wary of the police showing up at his
house any night and
charging him with uh you know attempted
murder again
is over but there has to be
accountability
to what happened not only to brianna but
what happened to kenny
because they clearly just charged kenny
in an attempted cover-up for brianna's
killing
and then that house of cards basically
just fell apart
easily and the charges against kenny are
dismissed and they just want to walk
away
and we've said repeatedly no it is not
okay to just walk away
there has to be a consequence because
without a consequence there's
never accountability i've heard people
say that you don't move on but you move
forward
there's several steps i'm taking as far
as the healing process but i mean of
course i talked to a therapist good
on the regular kenneth last time we
talked to you you weren't sure you were
going to do that
but my mind you know it's not right you
know every
nothing's right so you know
got to try new things in new situations
so with all the love and support that
brianna's receiving and i'm receiving
there's also a lot of hate too
you are receiving hate are you the most
famous one that i've seen is that people
said that i used brianna as a human
shield
oh my god that's that's been said on the
internet but like i said i mean if you
were to do
any type of research or look into
anything that's not even possible
but kenneth let's stop on that for just
a second what a cruel thing to say to
you
most definitely but these are things
that i have to deal with on the daily
so far well for me to be getting sued
you know for something like emotional
distress when i have to deal with things
like that every day
that's another slap in the face let's
talk about that because it raised a lot
of eyebrows when officer mattingly
the officer who was hit in the leg that
night
filed a counter suit against you
claiming alleged battery assault and
emotional distress
you heard that lawsuit and you thought
what i thought that's everything that
happened to me
but you know okay the truth always
wins so have you been able to go back to
work yet
no i've definitely not been able to go
back to work and
you know that's that's another thing
that i miss out on but even if i was
to be able to go to work right now it
wouldn't be normal when he's applying
for jobs people are asking you ever been
arrested
so the the reality of that situation is
he
has suffered both psychological and
economic damage as a result of what's
happened
right and someone's going to have to
rectify that and it's the parties that
we have sued we believe
last week walker filed a federal lawsuit
against the louisville city government
police department and officers involved
in the raid
he alleges they violated his fourth
amendment right to be free
from unreasonable searches what do you
miss most about
brianna everything
but i'd say on the daily like the help
that she gave me like even just
just simple things like remembering you
know what what day my phone bills do
stuff like that like i wouldn't have to
worry about that
well isn't it kenneth the simple things
isn't it
the everyday things you know that i'm
missing out on
are are we hurt the most
jefferson county commonwealth's attorney
tom wine told cbs news his office
dropped the charges against kenneth
walker
because it determined it did not have
sufficient evidence to prove his guilt
at trial
we also by the way reached out to the
kentucky attorney general that's daniel
cameron's office
the louisville metro police department
and sergeant mattingly's attorney
all parties declined to comment and
that's what struck me
at the end of the interview it's the
it's the simple things
being involved in a couple don't forget
to pay your phone you can i could bring
something because as soon as he said
that i could like i could
i know you know you always think about
the big things in life but it's the
small things i mean his life has been
permanently permanently changed as we
see and i thought his attorney fred
moore raised a good point when he said
when you fill out an application it says
have you been arrested that's something
that says that makes a big difference
but you know it's the little things but
i think about the big things too they
were
baby clothes i mean yeah yeah no telling
where they would be right now if not for
this intervention and in that lawsuit
they said listen it's not about money
but
certainly money gets people's attention
to lead to change and he's certainly
owed something for what he has been
through
so we'll be following these cases
certainly more to come